JEN PERSON: It's
officially week six
of Google Cloud
Next on air, which
means we're focusing on data
management and databases.
I'm Jen Person, and welcome
to "This Week in Cloud,"
where we're taking a sneak
peek at this week's content.
Week six is all about data
management and databases,
meaning we're highlighting how
Google's cloud databases are
simple to use, without
compromising on security,
liability or open standards.
We've got sessions on
data migration stories,
modernization advice, and
integrating everything
from your Cassandra workloads
to your existing SQL server.
So be sure to check out
the session catalog.
And don't forget to explore the
demos to see what you can do.
No matter what your data
solution looks like,
it needs to be reliable.
You need to be confident your
database service can recover
from user errors, infrastructure
failures, and full region
outages.
That's why we're shining
this week's spotlight
on high availability
and disaster
recovery with Cloud SQL.
This talk is packed full
of advice and insight
on how Cloud SQL
leverages replication
and automatic health checks
to keep your database online.
One session on my
own playlist is how
to choose the right database.
Because there are quite
a few options out there,
and the right one
for you depends
on what you're trying to do.
This talk will walk you through
the strengths of various Google
Cloud databases from the
perspective of different use
cases, from lift and
shift to modernization
of existing applications
and net new development,
this talk covers it all.
Of course, effective
data management
is about more than storing
and querying your data.
Those are just the
foundation building systems
that offer insights to
empower your business.
This video demo offers
an example of this
by showing one retailer can
use Cloud Spanner to build
a real time inventory
management system to support
their online sales.
To out these sessions to
your digital playlist,
check out the link.
Any ideas or thoughts,
leave us a comment
or tweet us using the
hashtag #GoogleCloudNext.
We'll see you in the cloud.